who is going to be the first team to
take over in CS2 it's a tricky thing to
predict the beginnings of this iteration
of Counter Strike are very different
from previous iterations the state of
the game isn't great and competition is
stiffer than ever the first taste of
professional CS2 is like a week away and
the first major just a few short months
everyone's grinding and rumors are
swelling but who's going to come out on
top
okay so before we get into it are you
already sick of CS2 Premiere good me too
so why not try our face it clan you can
join me your friends and the rest of our
community as we grind the leaderboards
win face it points and spend them in the
face it shop on cool things like skins
it's totally free to join you just need
to make a face it account so check out
the link in the description below okay
so professional
CS2 God what a weird thing to say csgo
is done it's gone forever officially For
Better or For Worse valve has switched
all of us over to counter- strike 2
including the pros now to be clear
forcing the switch was the right move in
so far as it was the only move at some
point we were going to have to bite the
bullet whether or not the game was ready
just would have been nice if the bullet
had actually registered you know suffice
it to say CS2 is not ready for
competitive play it is not even really
ready for casual play in fact it's not
really ready at all which as device
recently observed is okay for right now
the game does feel really bad like
there's no point in sugar coating it
everything from the peer's advantage to
the movement to the hit RG oh don't get
me started on the hit RG I have moments
where I just watch a bullet go through
someone's head see it not register and
think how and then other times I'll feel
feel like I'm missing their heads and
watch as I just rack up kill after kill
now valve did just release an update
that apparently improves the hitbox
issue but full disclosure I haven't had
a chance to try it yet and we'll see how
much of a difference it makes anyway
this is not a video about how not ready
CS2 is I mean it's not entirely about
that it's about how it's going to affect
the pro scene right now it is fair to
say that professional counter- strike is
probably more up in the air than at any
point in its 10 year history which may
seem obvious but keep in mind the last
time we switched from one Counter-Strike
to another Esports wasn't even a glimmer
of what it is today the reason you had
such immediate uncontested dominance
from the likes of nip and even very
games is because the scenes were so much
smaller forest and getright were gods of
1.6 and KES and shocks and rpk were the
best Sorcerers in the world two teams
buying for total control of Global
Offensive was wasn't actually that
unexpected but now it's anyone's for the
taking now there are certain rosters who
are let's say primed to be extremely
strong right out of the gate for
starters the rumored Falcon roster for
those who don't know a rumor emerged
late last week that the Saudi Arabian
Esports organization team Falcons were
looking to build aing state-of-the-art
super team that allegedly included Nico
twists mesy Dupri Magis and or boros
because of course super teams have
worked out so well for Nico in the past
as Cloud sets the push up oh oh it's
happened they made it work Cloud n are
your e League major
Champions memes aside would this roster
be insane oh of course absolutely but I
think we'd be jumping the gun if we just
assumed that they would be like the
number one straight Gunner right out of
the game first of all the the roster
isn't real yet second of all the guns
don't even work in CS2 let's let's cool
it on which Mega roster is going to take
over the game for now let's talk about
excellent rosters that do exist like
Vitality they just want a major their
roster is finally clicking the way we
always hoped it would and I mean you
know they have zyu who is statistically
right now the best Counter-Strike player
in the world now to be fair they did
sort of rup their Chemistry by dropping
Dupri in favor of flamy who could end up
becoming one of the game's next great
Superstars only time will tell that said
they also just lost zic which was really
stupid just no upside to that at all so
we'll have to see how things pan out
then you've got a roster like FaZe who
are basically just always and forever in
a position to dominate not only has robs
been labbing CS2 likeing crazy but these
are seasoned accomplished worldclass
counter Strikers with near perfect
Synergy sure they may not win every
tournament but you can never count out a
group of competitors such as this
they'll always be top tier it's just a
question of how top tier from there I
think it actually gets pretty uncertain
pretty fast for starters
na'vi I I don't know man I'm really
happy that they made the recent pro
league final and I think it's great for
the overall storylines of professional
CS that they got a nice little
confidence boost coming out of Global
Offensive simple hasn't been mincing
words when it comes to his ill opinion
of the current state of CS2 but that
doesn't mean that he will not continue
to be God's gift to Counterstrike for me
the question isn't really whether simple
will return to form but rather whether
na'vi as a whole thrives as an
international roster so far they seem to
be progressing faster than anticipated
so let's hope they keep it up G2 are a
weird one Nico looks determined to
finally start winning [__] consistently
and mesy is just on another [__] tier
of upand cominging talent but the roster
as a whole just feels very coin flippy
it's also worth noting that of all the
rosters that I've mentioned thus far G2
are the only one who still have
something to prove VAV winning a major
which carries a ton of weight when it
comes to grinding a whole new game from
here on out let's be honest it's a
crapshoot now I would have said that
heroic are shoeing to be great but their
recent extremely shocking decision to
part ways with Kaden has thrown their
top tier status into question in fact
should Kaden decide to join oh I don't
know let's say liquid take over oping
from OC take over IG yelling from Yi
bring Stan with him maybe he could maybe
just maybe turn liquid into a winning
roster who knows man these are weird
times we live in which honestly sums up
just about every roster evaluation at
this point M for instance just won pro
league which is sick we love that for
them but keep in mind a lot of the truly
top tier teams were already sort of
admittedly moving on from csgo and onto
CS2 does that mean that Ms are all of a
sudden an elite roster I mean probably
not in so far as they're no more or less
Elite than the Fanatics furias Cloud9
verus Pros Etc I think you can see where
I'm going with this which is that
Counter-Strike Esports has become so
evolved since the Advent of go that it's
no longer possible to single out even
two or three rosters that are just going
to dominate straight out of the gate
which is really really exciting I like
many others am so psyched to see the
pros duke it out on this brand new
busted ass Battlefield who knows what's
going to happen who's going to be good
who's going to be bad for how long it's
a tossup which is great it makes for
some really exciting Counterstrike I
know what you're thinking so the
takeaway Demetri is you have no idea
who's going to be great yeah pretty much
no one does and it's awesome we have no
idea how different or similar CS2 is
going to feel to csgo three or even 6
months down the line will it feel more
similar to csgo than go did to either
Source or 1.6 yes unquestionably but it
will be different maybe the op won't be
as good maybe the utility changes will
take a lot more getting used to than we
thought maybe the shotguns will worm
their way into the meta who knows but
it'll be really interesting to see how
it pans out IEM Sydney kicks off in less
than a week and truthfully none of us
know what to expect it's safe to say
that it'll probably be a disaster but
it'll be a super informative super
interesting and indeed super fun
disaster fun for us not for the players
it'll suck for them it's funny too cuz
I'm not a fan of mixed drinks at all
but hot totties is just hit different
bro like a late night hot totty oh maybe
I'll make one now yeah you know what I
mean yeah little bourbon little fuing
little lemon little honey yeah 9:35 in
the
morning it's 5:00 somewhere barely